there's some kind of trial that must be
passed
i know not the nature of it but
i do recognize the symbol of the tree of
knowledge
well
hey guys pete here well after a somewhat
slow start i think it's safe to say
things are starting to pick up and
raised by wolves season two this week we
officially entered the back half of the
season with episode five king and marcus
traded out his necro eyes for a tooth
and i guess that worked out for him
maybe verrill traded out her emotional
support animal for something a little
more stabby and i feel like we won't be
slowing down again until this season
comes to an end real quick there will be
spoilers if you haven't watched episode
5 yet and with that said let's get into
it the last episode ended with father
looking at his project floating above
the ground outside his shed and this
week you see him wake up to an ancient
android that looks fully functional he
tries to talk to her and there's no
response or at least she only makes
sounds and he's fascinated with this
veil that she wears that he tries to
touch and asks if she can remove it
before he can figure out what's going on
mother calls him and shows him a message
from holly that was delivered in an orb
that she found laying on the ground
saying that the church is her family now
and that she doesn't want them to come
after her mother is having none of that
and she says that father should go
because he's better with the children
she brings up his fighting billy and he
tells her he fears they're becoming too
human to be the parents their children
deserve she's also having none of that
and goes as far as accusing him of being
constantly distracted which is kind of
rich when you think about all the
problems that happened in the first
season because she was distracted with
entering the sim and visiting what she
thought was her creator campion sturgis
mother also stepped on sue's toes she
was running tests on paul's cocoon and
figured out that in 24 hours the
chemical composition inside there was
gonna dissolve his body mother said that
he's not dying he's actually evolving
but sue isn't exactly thrilled about
this because his humanity is dissolving
in there he's actually becoming a snake
the kids come to visit and of course
they're all worried and tempest also
tells sue that the people who were gonna
take her baby took off when mother shut
down the trust so now she doesn't know
what she's going to do before they leave
veda puts prayer beads near the window
outside of where paul is in the
collective you see that things are sort
of falling apart now that the trust has
been turned off hunter and tempest have
a conversation where he says he thinks
paul's going to die and she admits that
sometimes she misses having the idea of
saul that saul is listening to her she
misses that sometimes while they're
talking they hear noises coming from
father's shed and when they go inside
they discover the ancient android when
tempest walks up to her you see a
projection of her baby on the veil
almost like a sonogram it's like she's
scanning her and that freaks tempest out
so she leaves back at the tarantula
mother interrogates cleaver asking if he
knew the trust was going to sacrifice
paul he admits that he did and that he
still believes it was a sound decision
he tries to say the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of and she just
tortures the hell out of him she wants
to know what the antidote for paul is
and he can't tell her in the process of
all the torturing his glasses break and
she uses that to show him that he had
been reprogrammed by the trust that
people can be reprogrammed just like
androids father goes to lucius who's
locked up in the brig to get help to get
holly back and he makes an agreement to
help in exchange for being able to do
whatever he wants with marcus and the
others sue is running out of options
nothing is working to reverse what's
happening to paul she decides to send
the robot away and picks up the prayer
beads that vida left behind and starts
to pray she still manages to maintain
that she knows that it's not a god that
she's talking to she says it's a signal
sent by some alien somewhere but still
says hey if you can hear me this kid's
innocent it's not fair what's happening
he doesn't deserve this he loves you and
he's a true believer so she begs it to
make him better and pledges that she'll
do anything it wants in return a little
while later she wakes up and sees a
leech inside the chamber with paul that
freaks her out she puts on a suit and
she goes inside to remove it after she
puts it in a jar though it disappears
and it reappears inside her suit on her
face then she starts seeing them
everywhere and eventually realizes it's
a vision
she has a conversation with her digital
assistant and figures out that this is a
special type of leech that lives on the
acid water creatures we saw these
whenever the one attacked virile in the
last episode so she goes to collect some
and she brings campion along they're
able to lure one out of the water and
then use a gas canister to knock it out
and she is able to collect some samples
which she takes back and puts them on
paul's cocoon over at the marcus family
church decima is not in a good place
after killing virile and because marcus
has lost his magnetism she wants him to
attack the tarantula to try to get those
seeds without his powers he knows they
don't have a chance but he's still not
at a place where he wants to explain
where his powers came from or that he
lost them they argue about her killing
virile and justina and holly argue
because she doesn't want her to wear the
necklace with romulus's tooth on it
decima says it doesn't matter because
all the relics are fake that the
methraics made a ton of them but hawley
contends that it's real and that it has
powers and she can feel them sometimes
after asking her about romulus being a
king marcus takes it from her and he
wears it and then they discover another
one of those giant dodecahedrons a
pentagonal temple which is probably
really exciting for marcus because
you'll remember in the first season
that's where he first heard saul's voice
talk to him it's also where he became
the leader after the temple burned his
rival this temple isn't completely
intact it's damaged in a way that
they're able to enter it and inside it
they find a pit above that there's a
smaller dodecahedron on a chain that is
made to lower someone into it justina
inspects it and says there's a trial
that has to be passed she can't read all
the markings but can recognize the tree
of knowledge after decima eggs him on
marcus gets into the chair and they
start to lower him eventually he reaches
the bottom of the chain there's a big
serpent skeleton below where it stopped
that collapses when he crosses over it
to enter this tunnel that is actually
blocked by bones so he starts to clear
them back up on the surface it's raining
which i think this is the first time
we've ever seen that happen and i guess
this means it isn't acidic enough to
burn everyone up the mithraic faithful
are using their down time to get a
prayer circle going and then varial
returns to start picking them off with
ruthless efficiency she eliminates them
one by one and marcus gets the idea that
something might be going wrong on the
surface when justina goes screaming by
on her way to the bottom of the pit he's
on the mission so he continues digging
and varell continues slaughtering his
followers this was a pretty entertaining
sequence all the way around but i
thought her stabbing the kid with the
eye patch and his good eye was a
particularly nice touch when marcus
finally pushes his way through the
passage he finds a being slumped against
the wall it resembles what they
described as the devolved human that
tried to attack mother in the season 1
finale it's sort of wrapped in snake
skin and is carrying an intact metal
card that marcus pockets it opens its
eyes when he touches it and then
romulus's tooth starts to glow in
response to that i'd be lying if i said
the mechanics of what's happening here
all make sense in the moment but when it
starts making noises marcus tears it off
of his neck and throws it on the floor
it releases what looks like a gas that
makes its way over to the creature and
when it inhales it it transforms into
one of the creatures we saw coming out
of the pits in season one after a brief
struggle marcus shoots it and then sees
that his ride is taking off the chair is
going back up but he is able to leap and
climb inside as it's ascending
decima makes a break for it she's going
for the tank she totally leaves holly
behind and when she gets there she
thinks she's escaped but actually virile
is already inside there too there's a
brief moment where decima thinks she
might be able to talk her way out of
what happened but her android is talking
literally when she says she wants her to
understand what it's like to get your
face cut off after she does that she
drags her body back to the pit and hangs
it up and it's the first thing marcus
encounters when he gets back to the
surface he's reunited with holly who is
the only survivor but while they're
burning the dead bodies father and
lucius arrived to bring her home lucius
is fairly upset that father won't let
him kill marcus on the spot but holly
had jumped in the way she's right there
she's freaking out that he's really the
prophet so they end up just taking him
prisoner although father does say that
he'll keep his promise to let lucius do
what he wants with him the leeches were
effective in saving paul from becoming a
snake it appears that he's making a full
recovery but who knows if there will be
any lingering effects he's delighted to
learn that sue got the idea when she
prayed again she explains that she
thinks the voice is something alien
rather than a god but he doesn't believe
that for a second it was soul as far as
he's concerned all of this seems to work
to help him put his animosity towards
her aside and i suppose they'll both
learn soon that marcus has been captured
sue is still on the hook to the voice
though and the episode ends with it
telling her to grow the seeds which is
referring to the box that paul found
that is now presumably somewhere in the
tarantula she says i'll do anything you
want just keep him safe as it cuts to
black so wow virile really thinned out
the cast in her quest for revenge i was
really surprised that they killed off so
many people especially decima and
tamerlane since they were just
introduced as new characters not many
misreacts left at this point either
although there were three victims that
went into the pit so who knows there
might be something going on there in the
beginning of the season it was all about
number seven is he going to be a threat
then we had this ancient android but it
was virile that really racked up a body
count hard to say how campion's gonna
react to that he was definitely feeling
her and hey she's still out there her
story is not over it's almost comical
now when i think back to the
anticipation i had of marcus finding
some major clue at the bottom of the pit
i figured he would find another mural or
something along those lines but nope
just another creature who is i don't
know allergic to ancient earth teeth
such a weird little trip into the pit
there although i gotta say him seeing
the body come flying by as he's clearing
the bone wall was a pretty awesome setup
also i did watch the episode extra for
this one where the showrunner gave some
more information about what was
happening there he says this creature is
somewhere between a human and one of the
other creatures the ones we saw
scurrying around on all fours it's
something that didn't allow itself to
devolve all the way then he said that
the tooth kind of disintegrated into
these little nanobots and then suddenly
this creature starts to devolve it made
for a crazy episode and got me a lot
more hyped up for the ones that are
still left i suppose the card that
marcus took from him that's going to
turn out to be important and since he's
been taken prisoner that's probably
going to get confiscated either way now
that sue is working for the voice he's
got somebody on the inside and i'm sure
that box is gonna get opened and we're
gonna find out what's going on there so
things are looking pretty good like i
said i thought that we would learn a
little bit more about father's android
we're still just kind of getting the
tease there and really number seven has
been on the bench for the last two
episodes so hopefully we'll get some
movement with him as well mother and
father's conversation kind of pointed
out how things have strayed away from
the primary focus of course she's making
moves to protect her children like
shutting down the trust but all of that
is made more complicated by number
seven's existence which they're keeping
a secret as to how she's connected plus
they still haven't explained what they
learned about the planet and just in
general there is a lot of situations
where people aren't telling the whole
truth father does seem to be pretty
absorbed in his project and how could he
not be hopefully it'll start talking or
communicating soon the projection of
tempus baby felt like it might be
protective to humans to me not sure what
everyone else thinks about that that
baby is coming and that seems like it'll
probably be important and i think that
would be a good place to leave things so
a lot to look forward to let me know in
the comments what you're thinking about
what you thought about this episode what
you're hoping to see for the rest of the
season please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon